we are the bridge on all those sorts of
issues where the Republicans have no
other bridges so maybe we should put up
a toll road to make them pay to come
across but we are the bridge to the
Millennials I don't think there's any
question about that hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with reason TV today we're
talking with John Dennis he's a
businessman in San Francisco a
recidivist congressional candidate who
runs against Nancy Pelosi for the
republican party in San Francisco John
thanks for talking to it's my pleasure
thanks for having me you've had a pretty
pretty good success against Nancy Pelosi
what motivates you and why do you do
well a couple of things be Nancy Pelosi
is pretty much the almost awful person
in Congress on so many different levels
explain that a little well I mean just I
mean Sheila she and I will never share
an opinion on on economic policy and
what would advance you know the progress
of man but but she's also really a
disaster on civil liberties issues to
you know the NSA people are concerned
about it they started warrantless
wiretapping this Folsom Street 18t
building 10 years ago maybe she could
have nipped it in the bud but instead
she was brief and did nothing about it
and today we have you know this full
blossom does spy state why do Liberal
Democrats often get a pass on things
like civil liberties issues I mean one
of the things I mean Obama campaigned
about pulling back from the excesses of
the Bush era and then you know when he
was found out it was you know it was
hypocrisy and people were disappointed
but a lot of people like Dianne
Feinstein the senator from Northern
California Nancy Pelosi I mean there
there are a lot of Democrats who are
just terrible on civil liberties issues
people to wound up in the in the in the
red vs blue fight that's really the
answer people can only absorb one or two
choices in the you know if they get
involved in hating Republicans they're
never going to vote against the other
person when you run against Pelosi and
you and you're running again in 2014 I
am now what what's your basic pitch to
San Francisco residents to get rid of
viña the highest ranking Democrat in the
house no the two thoughts one she voted
against Conyers Amash the Condors Amash
was the bill that came up last year that
would have defunded the NSA and so it
she could have helped their our privacy
helped expand our privacy but it has a
practical impact in San Francisco and
that a lot of money has been diverted
out of the bay area from tech companies
because cut because companies overseas
don't want to do business when they feel
like they're being spied on it has it
rec practical impact on the Bay Area
sick Nancy Pelosi is bad for the Bay
Area economy what will you consider
success short of actually unseating
Pelosi which is unlikely what what
countless accessory you always run to
win never say that we're not going to
but I think you know the republican
party in San Francisco this is a common
thing in urban environments has been
going down in voter registration for
decades until 2001 seen continued in
2010 but our performance was a breakaway
in the trend in terms of how
congressional candidates did I'd like to
continue that trend I'd like to get up
and I think it's going to be a low
turnout year and I think we'll probably
do a lot better maybe triple
registration base that would be nice to
do what happened to the Republican Party
in California I mean this is a you know
California is a massive state it's
hugely important because of its size but
also its bellwether status up through
the mid 90s there was a functioning
republican party here that did extremely
well and hosted a diverse range of
opinions that the republican party is
practically in receivership here maybe
they could have made and put out a
handshake to the to the immigrant
community maybe didn't do that and
during Pete Wilson's time in office I
think they haven't been in a lot of
competitive races and don't know how to
compete anymore so I think those are two
reasons but I also think that you know
the resurgence of the Republican Party I
think lies in what this conference is
all about which is you know connecting
people with the concept of individual
liberty using individual liberty it's
sort of the gateway drug to come back
into the Liberty wing of the Republican
Party right do you in California you
know it tends to be much more socially
tolerant than other parts of the country
not exclusively but oftentimes the the
state economy is and it is just a hell
in a handbasket is there a natural
libertarian constituency in California
and if so where can they go to vote that
will look at the San Francisco there are
all these libertarian threads over time
that run through San Francisco and I
think the only home for them sorry to
say is in the Republican Party I mean
that's that's where we've focused our
efforts is sort of concentrating on
growing that wing of the Republican
Party think I'm afraid to say that the
Democrats there's no democratic liberty
caucus reason recently did a poll a
national poll of millennial
only twenty-two percent of Millennials
say the Republican are lean that way the
Millennials are the future of American
politics there are 80 million strong
there that they're the demographic bulge
that's going to be dictating you know
the next 50 years of American policy how
can the Republicans start to connect
with Millennials who say that they are
socially liberal they believe in gay
marriage they believe in drug
legalization they believe in you know
I'm line gambling and all sorts of
autonomy issues but there are so
fiscally centrist they want a government
that spends less and spends it better
you know how do Republicans connect with
that well I think the establishment of
the Republican Party has been a little
bit slow on the uptake and it's sort of
push back against this Liberty wing I
think that's really like I said it's the
gateway drug we are the bridge on all
those sorts of issues where the
Republicans happen to other bridges so
maybe we should put up a toll road to
make them pay to come across but we are
the bridge to the Millennials I don't
think there's any question about that
what we'll end it there John Dennis of
San Francisco running against Nancy
Pelosi in the fall thanks so much for
talking to reason TV thank you for
having for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie